so I know when collision occurs I know
what a collision occurs now let me just
read the wording of this question for
you so that you can see what you're
going to have to do find correct to the
nearest degree the obtuse angle between
the directions of motion of the
particles that the instant their collide
ok so can see they're going to come
together now I don't know much about the
actual directions of things because
remember at the very beginning the
question this gave us these they just
handed us these questions of
displacement so I don't know anything
about the velocity equations at the
moment at the moment ok how do I work
that out where do I go if I want to know
the velocity yeah I'm have to
differentiate so you usually would have
started from acceleration and integrated
up to here but being that this is my
starting point I'm going to
differentiate this can you get a head
start on me can you work that out while
I rot some space off
me
sorry do you need that that's okay i'll
show you my I've got already
Oh
hey
and
by some we have velocity that maybe I
might as well pick up where we are you
can see here right what have I done this
is I'm just working on the first
particle okay now this is a general
statement from any velocity any angle of
projection but for the first particle
I've got a particular velocity a
particularly good projection and I've
been given both of these prior right so
I think what you've got is from the
first time here 40 is a 40 or is it
birdie let's see you know it's 30 the
first one is 30 and I believe this is
the angle that you will find yes so
remembering just like we did before word
in this right angle triangle what's
going on this is going to be 30 times
its the other two sciences it's
three-fifths which of course is so I
have a horizontal of what city for this
okay that's fine so I'm going off in
this direction okay I need to know
what's happening vertically as well if
you want some angles you need your
horizontal edge of vertical so therefore
i'm going to say y dot over here so i'm
just going to try to condense as much as
I can minus GT I know gravity is I'm
just to fight it out to attend today's
minus y plus okay what are the other
pieces what are you going to get this is
sign of that sine inverse right we did
this really really early what does this
represent because this is the same this
is the sent this is gravity this is the
longer you've been flying the more it's
pulling you down right and eventually
it's going to overcome whatever this
happened to be okay let's work it out
when you've got minus 40 plus 30 times
four fifths 30 times for Fitz is
so what's happened be careful sign and
director really matters here right so in
other words enough time has progressed
enough time has progressed here that the
gravity is pulled down on this and this
object is now coming on its back on the
down right so now i can kind of finish
our part of this diagram this is where
it began but I've actually gone further
now so something a little bit like this
ok so now I know that's how far i bought
into the motion in the same way now I
can do this for the second particle I'm
just going to say some time because
you're going to rehearse everything he
are but you're going to do it for V 2
theta 2 all that kind of thing when time
equals four X naught is equal to equal
to ok here we go
mm-hmm I've got a negative here once you
work it out why do I have an idiot
because it's going in the opposite
reason it started from the right let's
going to the left ok so my horizontal
displacement is going to be negative
right toward the origin when you have a
look at why not if you go ahead and get
your numbers this happens to also be
minus 16 ok that's somewhat come
incidental so when I complete out my
diagram it's going to look like this
here we go and there's my point of
collision there ok now what was the
question asking do you remember he was
looking for own up to saying oh very
good so it's going to be this angle here
now at this point the usefulness of this
diagram has ended ok it's nice it shows
us what's very roughly going on but it
won't help me calculate things ok as you
remember in some of your early questions
you would have joined a box to show ok
there's my angle of projection and in
the same way you can draw a box to show
your angle of impact you had something
like that ok but here two particles are
interacting with each other yeah two
particles so fact I'm not just getting
this I'm happy having something coming
from the opposite side as well so
conveniently because they both have the
same vertical component here this is
actually why I 1 and this is all shoot
ok I'm going to draw myself a new
diagram it's going to look like this
okay now I've draw this really really
why because I have to fit two particles
into this thing okay ones coming from
the left ones coming from the right I've
got some proportions here too yeah which
one is traveling faster toward the point
of impact x2 is traveling faster right
so therefore it's going which is
actually quite true s is gone that way
okay and it's almost it's almost double
do you agree with that it's almost all
so therefore i'm gonna put a dotted line
in here okay so her she got it okay so
you can see I've got the first particle
going that way and then I've got my
second particle coming in from the
opposite direction now it's a lot
clearer or what angle i'm actually trade
calculated okay I've got my Y dot which
is negative 16 it's the same thing over
here which like I said is a coincidence
and then I'm going to put some other
numbers on to hear right so let's put on
x1 dot which is 18 and I can put x two
dot as well remember it's negative cuz
heading in the other direction okay so
with the angle I'm trying to work out
it's this one in this blue red black
triangle right so I'm going to give some
names these things I'm call that beat up
and we're going to call this alpha so
can someone tell me what kind of
expression should I write to work out
that total size of this angle okay so
alpha plus beta which is equal to have a
look at the information you've got and
what's going to be the best ratio in
these right-angled triangles shoes have
a look at early for example if you just
think about alpha you have this guy here
and you got this leg that's the opposite
and adjacent right kids 10 so I'm going
to go to work out alpha it's telling us
of opposite on adjacent
yeah yeah so do you do now because what
I'm trying to work out is the magnitude
of an angle I'm not going to worry about
any negatives here okay that's alpha and
then I need me up so that's 10 inverse
of what its opposite on the sama Jason
right so this is happens to be too okay
so you can go ahead you calculate oh gee
I guess I think you get like 100 11.8
blah blah blah blah does that seem like
a reasonable answer it does right number
one we expected to be a tus number two
it's further to give in the range there
right you remember you expect this to be
I've tried my best you know we talked
about like people are de- my diagram
have to be to scale no it does it but
you're doing yourself a disservice if
you don't draw diagrams to scale because
then you have very little mechanism for
what here am I in the right ballpark or
not and my diagrams not too bad okay I
think they asked for this to the nearest
degree and there's your angle ok so to
rewind right where we began because
they're trying to be nice to us and
realized how much work we had to do they
gave us these equations of displacement
we didn't have to integrate to get all
the way there ok but then we ended goes
through through a series of moves to try
and work out ok if they collide which
equations am I going to combine how am I
going to solve to find the particular
numbers that I've got an hour pops and
answered you need to physically
interpret ok